sur ces images fournies par les services
de secours ukrainien on peut voir un
quartier entier réduit ensemble selon
les autorités locales au dessin était
frappé par cette missiles lundi soir
tiré depuis la péninsule de Crimée
contre les par la Russie ce port situé
sur la mer Noire et tu as une centaine
de kilomètres des trous mais il est
régulièrement frappé depuis plusieurs
jours lors d'une visite surprise dans la
ville quelques heures plus tôt le
président du Conseil européen a été
forcé de s'abriter alors qu'un missile
s'abattait dans les environs
le Kremlin veut exécuter votre esprit de
liberté et de démocratie mais je suis
totalement convaincu qu'il n'y
parviendront jamais à l'est du pays
l'offensive de Moscou se poursuit dans
le don-basse l'armée ukrainienne semble
reculer aux abords de sévero de netk
l'une des plus grandes villes sous
contrôle ukrainien et de cramatorzek où
les combats font rage entre les deux
camps je sais que l'Ukraine vaincra quoi
qu'il arrive on se battra jusqu'à la
dernière goutte de sang sur le front une
immense fumée noire celle d'une
raffinerie que les Russes bombardent
depuis dimanche les troupes ukrainiennes
ont en revanche repris plusieurs
villages plus au nord près de kerkiv
elles sont parvenues à repousser les
trous brusses à plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres de la deuxième ville du crâne